-Our next guest
is a talented actor you know
from his work in films
such as "Y tu mamá también,"
"The Motorcycle Diaries,"
and "Coco,"
and shows such as
"Mozart in the Jungle"
and "Station Eleven."
His latest project, "Cassandro,"
is available now on Prime Video.
Let's take a look.
♪♪
[ Indistinct shouting ]
[ Crowd chanting in Spanish ]
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
-[ Shouting Spanish ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[Chanting "Cassandro"]
Cassandro! Cassandro!
-Please welcome back to the show
Gael García Bernal, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Gael!
-Yes. Thank you so much.
It's so nice to be here again.
-This is a film about a world
I will admit
not knowing much about.
This is lucha libre wrestling.
Tell us about exactly
what that means.
-I'm surprised --
You never played that
with your friends, you know?
-We did, like, world wrestling,
but not the sort of,
yes, the Mexican style.
-The Mexican style. Okay, okay.
So it's, uh -- Lucha libre.
It's, uh, wrestling.
Uh, the translation
is, like, "free wrestling."
So it's free.
It's very much
you can do anything.
It's, uh --
It's got two ramifications
that are very specific.
You know, like, sort of
the teams, you know?
It's técnicos, technicians,
and the rudos,
the rude ones, and --
Or the rough ones. Sorry.
The rough ones.
That would be the translation..
And, eh, it's the same.
[ Laughter ]
And they, uh, you know --
there's many strands there,
where one of them
is the exoticos.
-Okay.
-Which are, like, the campy,
uh, wrestlers, you know,
and, uh, Cassandro,
amongst his contemporaries --
Cassandro is the character
I interpret in the film.
Uh, amongst his contemporaries,
they were the first ones
to subvert, more or less,
the notion that people
had about exoticos
because they came out,
uh, openly gay,
and, uh, people started
to support them
and people started to make them
want to win and, uh --
And, yeah. Yeah...
See the movie. See the movie.
See the movie.
-So, Cassandro
is the wrestling name
of a real person called Saúl.
-Yes.
-And, um, were you aware
of him growing up?
Was he sort of famous enough
to be on your radar?
-Well, he was -- He came
a little bit afterwards.
You know, as a kid,
I mean, I was watching,
uh, lucha libre on the TV,
and I saw many wrestlers
like Atlantis, Octagon,
Rayo de Jalisco.
I mean, amazing,
like, legends, no?
Uh, and Cassandro
came a little bit after.
You know,
because there's a point
where you get a little bit
embarrassed of watching the...
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah?
So, uh, yeah. Cassandro came
a little bit afterwards.
-You did get to meet
the real Cassandro.
-Of course!
-Uh, there you are.
-Yeah, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-He must have been, uh --
I would imagine
he was so excited
that you were
all taking the time
to tell a story like this.
-He was very excited, yeah,
and, you know, just delighted
that we would also take on
the fact that, you know,
Saúl created Cassandro,
created this character
in order to find himself,
you know, in order
to see all the dimensions
of who he could be.
And that led him in the road
to discovery, you know?
He was very happy,
I think, of what we did --
is that we also created
our own Cassandro,
and, uh, it took me on a path
of discovery, as well.
And I think you can
tell that in the movie.
It has that kind of, like --
that kind of, you know,
just a lot of nirvana moments,
you know,
of fascination.
And also allowed me
to play a luchador,
you know, that as a kid,
I used to trash my room
with my friends and my brother.
You know, we used to --
And, uh --
And now I was doing it for real
in the ring.
-He probably appreciated not
just that you told his story,
but you --
you took it seriously.
You tried to
get into wrestling shape.
Is this accurate?
-Yeah.
-Did you enjoy the training?
-I enjoyed -- Okay.
So, at the beginning, it was --
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you for your honesty.
We all know where this is going.
-Everything -- Like all stories,
it begins well.
-Yeah.
-It begins me eating a lot
and gaining a lot of weight
and, you know, doing a lot of,
uh, strength exercises,
you know, calisthenics
and those kind of things.
And then -- then two months
before starting to shoot,
I started to do
the wrestling training.
-Yeah.
-And that, uh -- Ah.
That's just like --
I mean, as a warmup,
for example,
you have to do
100, like, dead falls
to the ground,
you know, like "tlack!"
Yes? Yes. Oh-ho. Yeah?
Yeah, because you have to learn
how to fall.
-Right.
-You know? And, uh --
And that's just to begin with,
and that's just the warmup.
And if you were like one minute
late, they would come --
All the wrestlers
that you're training with,
they would come
and rush towards you
and hit you as hard as you can,
and you had to fall
and go back again on top.
And then another person.
Dah! Dah-dah!
And obviously all of them
are bigger than me.
And, you know, it was like...
-And nobody at any point
stepped in and said,
"This is the star of the movie.
You leave this poor man alone."
-Oh. I think in the wrestling
world and in Mexico,
you would say that,
they would hit me even more.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's like, "No, no.
He's just train--
He's just training here."
-Did you do -- Was there
anything you had to do,
any sort of physical stunt
where you thought to yourself --
Because I'm older than you,
but not by a lot.
And there are certain things
I do now where I think,
"Oh, I wasn't ready for that."
Was there any moment
where you were like,
"What am I doing here?"
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But the good thing is that --
I mean, we shot this
with our own --
with our film family, you know?
So, the stunt coordinator
is called Balo Bucio,
and he's fantastic.
And he was the interlocutor
with a wrestling organization
that we worked with, which is...
And they were really kind
and very giving.
And they -- From the beginning,
they were like,
"No, you can do this.
You can do this."
And I was like, "I --
No, I can't. I can't do that."
They were like,
"Yeah, you'll manage.
You'll manage to do this."
And indeed I managed
to do all of the stunts
except one -- except two.
But one very, very clear,
which is called
the Cassandro Bomb.
-Okay.
-Not even Cassandro
is allowed to do it
because it's illegal, you know?
So it's like --
-What is --
Now you have to explain it.
What's an illegal
Cassandro Bomb?
-Oh, man. I, um -- I'd have to
show it, but then...
-No, no, no.
-There wouldn't be a witness
to talk about it like that.
-We're like,
"We're sorry Gael died,
um, but do see his movie."
Hey. Thanks for being here.
It is a really special film.
And it's so nice
to see you again.
-Thank you so much.
-Gael García Bernal, everybody.
"Cassandro" is streaming now
on Prime Video.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with more "Late Night."